yesterday we had that horrific attack on
um a maternity hospital
can you just share your thoughts on on
that particular attack it defies words
really it what it what it tells me kind
of watching this um is that it's a
deliberate targeting of civilians that
it's cynical that there is no way to
write this off as an accident a missile
that's gone astray um and uh and russia
has formed in previous theaters of doing
this so it's if anything really it
confirms that um putin's intention here
is about more than just taking out
strategic military targets when he says
he wants to go after the country he
means he wants to go after the country
and that makes this incredibly serious
the ukrainian government is asking with
increasing urgency to close their skies
why aren't we imposing a no-fly zone now
it's a hugely emotive issue this uh
a no-fly zone i completely understand it
and i'm being asked that by uh several
of my ukrainian friends that too is a
really difficult judgment for um world
leaders to make um but it's also really
clear that in so doing you bring other
countries including nuclear capability
countries into conflict um with a
country that itself is a is a nuclear
country so
you know i don't envy frankly world
leaders by having to have that continual
debate in your opinion have we ever been
at a greater risk of of world war three
than we are right now given everything
that's at play it's quite hard to tell
history will tell and i think it's too
early actually to to say and i tend not
to want to
not want to deal in
you know apocalyptic sort of prophecies
about the thing it's perfectly possible
and i also think to be honest it's uh
it's part of putin's narrative i think
it even helps for him to escalate it to
that level because it's a goading if you
like to uh to the west to become
involved in this conflict but then if
you like almost self-fulfills the
prophecy
as i said before i'm focused on what we
can do to help ukraine here and now um
to achieve what they seem very very
determined to achieve which is to push
back